الجيش الاوكراني قال انه اسقط 18 طائره
مسيره ايرانيه الصنع من طراز شاهد اطلقتها
القوات الروسيه من بحر ازوف هنا
ومعظمها 18 - 24 معظمها طبعا باتجاه مدن
الجنوب وايضا باتجاه العاصمه كييف خصوصا
السلطات الاوكرانيه قالت ان حطام ثلاثه
طائرات هناك في هذه المنطقه حيث اسقطت هذه
الطائرات القوات الاوكرانيه
سقطت في مناطق سكنيه
والحقت اضرارا بسيارات وبالممتلكات في
تفصيل هذه المسيرات ايضا في الجنوب قالت
القوات الاوكرانيه انها اسقطت اربع طائرات
مسيره في ميكولايف هنا وايضا في اوديسا
تحدثت القوات الاوكرانيه عن اسقاط نحو
اثني عشر طائره مسيره على الاقل لكن ثلاث
من هذه الطائرات
لم تنجح القوات الاوكرانيه في اسقاطها في
اوديسا طبعا نشرت مصادر اوكرانيه صورا
لذيل اثنتين من هذه المسيرات وعليها هذه
الكتابه بخط اليد كما تلاحظون بهذه الصور
كتب على واحده منها من اجل الكريم وعلى
الاخرى من اجل موسكو فيما يبدو ردا على ما
تم الاعلان عنه في الكرملين امس لكن اكبر
الاضرار طبعا في الجنوب كانت في خرسون
التي عاشت ليله من القصف الشديد هنا في
جنوب البلاد وفقا للسلطات الاوكرانيه قتل
نحو خمسين شخصا في قصف صاروخي وقصف
بالطائرات المسيره وتفيد وكالات الانباء
وتفيد الانباء في داخل خرسون ان السكان
هنا يجمعون المؤن لاستعدادا للاحتماء في
الملاجئ ولرد الروسيا العنيف قد يستمر في
الايام لاسيما ان خيرسون كما تلاحظ هي
تتاخم جبهات القتال حيث هنا مناطق السيطره
الروسيه داخل جنوب اوكرانيا وهنا مناطق
السيطره التي استعادتها اوكرانيا من روسيا
الجبهه الشرقيه
المعتاده في دومباس كما العاده شهدت قصفا
في المناطق المتاخمه لباخموت التي تحاول
القوات الروسيه طبعا منذ اشهر تحاول هذه
القوات الهجوم والتقدم لاستعاده
او للسيطره على طبعا القوات الاوكرانيه من
جبهتها تقول انها ما زالت تصد هذه الهجمات
وتحافظ على مواقعها غرب المدينه وعلى هامش
هذه المعارك ايضا هناك قصف صاروخي على
مناطق متاخمه لاسيما
وخلف طبعا صورا لدمار كبير في مباني هذه
المدينه في الحدود الروسيه المتاخمه
لاوكرانيا اخيرا وهنا في داخل الاراضي
الروسيه قال حاكم مقاطعه
انه ان القوات اسقطت طائره مسيره اوكرانيه
وكذلك طائره اخرى تم اسقاطها هنا جنوبا في
داخل الاراضي الروسيه